I've spent more than a decade coaching
public speakers and helping people bring
their presentations to the next level,
and I have heard some bad public
speaking advice over that time. In this
video, I'm going to share the worst
pieces of public speaking advice and why
you should avoid these suggestions at
all costs. The worst piece of public
speaking advice, and you've all heard
it. You know what I'm going to say.
Imagine the audience in their underwear.
What?
Where did this come from? This is crazy.
It's creepy. It's weird, and there's no
basis of truth to it.
I guess the idea of doing so is
something like you take a scary audience
of people and you put them in a
vulnerable state, and that gives you
more confidence, but here's why I don't
like that.
By going with this reference and going
down that frame of thought, you are sort
of vilifying the audience. Like they are
this negative group of people who are
out to get you and are going to scowl
and not enjoy your speech.
That's not the case.
I think an audience really wants to
enjoy any speaker.
And sure, they will give their genuine
reaction, but within themselves, they
probably really want to see you succeed
on stage. And by doing a few basic
fundamental things, you can do exactly
that. You can connect with that
audience. You can get them laughing. You
can get them engaged.
But rather than put them in a weird
vulnerable underwear position, here's
what I actually suggest you do.
Look for those friendly faces.
Some people have the the resting face
that looks pretty aggressive where they
have a perma-scowl,
and if you pay too much attention to
those people, that's where you can get
in your head, but look for the people
who are smiling. For the people who are
looking up at you, nodding their heads,
and lock eyes with those people.
I still encourage you to to scan the
rest of the room, but when you finish a
thought, go back to those friendly faces
in the audience. That is the sort of
thing that's going to give you real
confidence.
If you use humor and you hear somebody
laughing, lock in with that person.
That is going to give you that boost of
energy.
It's going to make you feel like things
are going really well, and that is going
to be far more effective than picturing
your audience in their underwear. Please
don't do that. Another piece of bad
public speaking advice is to memorize
your speech word-for-word.
In theory, that sounds like it would be
a really good idea. You take the time to
write out a full speech, the more times
you practice, you know it in your head.
What I don't like about this tactic is
it creates zero room for adaptability.
If you are just trying to memorize every
single word, every sentence, exactly how
it was written out on a piece of paper
or on a word document,
you're limiting your ability to go with
the flow.
Let's say something happens in the room,
somebody speaks up, they put up their
hand, they ask a question, there's a
distraction that happens that cap that
gets everyone's attention, and it would
be weird for you as the speaker to not
recognize what just happened.
Then all of a sudden, that's the type of
thing if we've memorized a speech
word-for-word, where we are frozen
because we
we don't know anything other than what
we've exactly practiced.
What I think is far more effective is
the ability to learn chunks or have
various ideas. And sure, you can
practice it and it will probably be
similar over time, but it doesn't have
to be exactly the same because here's
the secret.
The audience doesn't know what you've
written down on a piece of paper for
your notes or how you went about
building your speech. And if you forget
to mention something that when you had
practiced previously you had mentioned,
nobody knows.
Nobody knows that that was something
that was supposed to be integrated into
your speech that you left out. They only
know what you are presenting to them.
The other downside about trying to
memorize word for word is it's really
easy to get derailed.
So, if you forget a sentence or
something,
you're stuck. You're handcuffed to this
presentation that you've been practicing
and memorized word for word. Far more
higher likelihood that you freeze on
stage because you don't know where to
go.
But if you've practiced adaptability, if
you've built your speech into general
categories or chunks that allow you to
go different ways,
now that's no problem. If you forget a
train of thought, you can easily adapt
and transition or just jump to the next
concept or idea.
A good way to guide you here, a final
tip, is if you're using PowerPoint
slides or some sort of slide
presentation,
just have a visual. You don't have to
write down all the words that you're
going to say, just have a big image with
a photo that triggers your memory of
what the general category is to talk
about. And then that way, you kind of
have notes, which are visual notes, that
remind you of the general category, but
building a speech this way doesn't get
you handcuffed to try and read out a
speech perfectly verbatim. There is
another common form of speaking advice,
which I would categorize as bad or
untrue.
And I think the spirit or the idea
behind this particular idea
has some logic.
And what it references is the fact that
people have short attention spans.
And with all of the distractions going
on that we're only able to focus on
something for a short amount of time.
So the piece of bad advice is to always
keep your speech short and sweet. I
think it completely matters on the
context of what the situation is. I
don't think it necessarily has to be
short,
but it has to be compelling.
You see people will give their attention
if they are drawn in. If they think that
they're getting value from a particular
speaker,
it doesn't matter if that speaker
presents for an hour, 2 hours, 90
minutes.
The audience, if they're getting value,
will continue to give their attention
and stay locked in.
But it doesn't even matter if you're
giving a 5-minute presentation. If
you're not giving value, if you're not
compelling, if you haven't structured it
in a way that's going to get the
audience's attention,
it's not going to connect that way
either. So this advice of no matter what
keeping your speech short and sweet,
I get the spirit behind it, but it's not
necessarily always true. I think you
want to hook your audience's attention.
Three ways to do this: start with a
story, ask a thought-provoking question,
or give a powerful stat, then give value
through the body of your speech, and
then conclude it, ideally by wrapping
full circle. This is one of the worst
pieces of public speaking advice that
I've ever heard, and it has to do with
PowerPoint or slide presentations.
And this is a common mistake. I've been
to a lot of speeches and I've seen,
especially amateur speakers, do this.
And what it is, the piece of advice that
is not good advice,
is to read along with the audience so
that they can follow along and read the
information that's on your slides.
Terrible idea. Here's all the problems
with it. If you have a bunch of text on
your slide and it's projecting behind
you and you're going to read that text
to the audience, one, it sort of signals
that you don't actually know that much
about the information. You're just
reading along with them. You haven't
internalized this.
Two, it takes away something called body
language, which is so powerful and is
what helps us immerse the audience in
whatever we're talking about because
we're turning our backs to them in order
to read the words on a screen. And let's
face it, how boring is that? We don't
want to watch a presenter just read to
us, especially turning away to read to
us and probably not hearing their voice
projected properly as well.
Your information, whatever you're
talking about, you don't need to have it
all written on your slides.
People are going to be distracted. The
text is probably going to be too small.
People aren't going to be able to read
it anyway.
What is much better is to have large
images,
maybe one or two words of text. I'm
talking 100-point
font so people can see it from anywhere.
And it's just an idea or something that
triggers to whatever you're talking
about. This gives you the freedom to
walk across the stage, to make eye
contact with the audience, to use vocal
variety, and do all of those sorts of
elements that help make any speech
compelling.
Do not write everything you're saying on
the slide and definitely don't turn your
back to the audience to read that
information. There is a lie that you may
have been told when it comes to public
speaking.
And this is something that is perhaps
romanticized by people because we love
the idea of just being able to wing it
when it comes to giving a speech. To get
up without any preparation and deliver a
compelling
thought-provoking
speech that creates a standing ovation
afterward and that everybody loves and
connects with. And I am not saying these
unicorn humans don't exist who can have
that skill to
at a moment's notice, completely
impromptu, deliver something that is
really powerful. Those people exist.
But they're the vast minority.
Most of us, myself included, are much
much better served from practicing.
Practicing whatever it is that we're
going to speak to our audience about.
And one of the worst pieces of advice or
a lie is this idea that speakers are
born, they're not made.
This is just a talent that you that you
have.
And there's nothing you can do about it.
If you're not a great speaker,
you weren't born that way. Sorry. And if
you're a good speaker,
you must have just gotten that talent
naturally. Surely you didn't work at it.
This is a lie.
I have seen so many examples, especially
through my years of being a Toastmasters
member, of people who were frightened,
who did not have strong public speaking
skills, who would stumble every single
sentence. And then they worked on their
craft. They honed it. They practiced.
And all of a sudden,
much quicker than you'd think, within a
few months, maybe a year,
this look like a different person.
The confidence,
the ability to stand in front of the
audience, not use any notes, and just
speak, and bring them in, draw them in
with stories.
This is possible for you as well, even
if you think, "I am not a public
speaker. I am not good at this." That is
just a mindset. I promise. I seen so
many examples of people who were not
born public speakers, who turned into
phenomenal communicators.
So, the decision is up to you, but do
not believe the lie that speakers are
born and not made. For somebody who
creates a lot of content about public
speaking skills that can help you, it
was a lot of fun doing something
completely reverse and telling you the
bad public speaking advice that's out
there, some of the worst advice. So, I
hope you avoid those things at all
costs. I hope this video added some
value to you, and please know, if you
are a professional, you are somebody who
wants to elevate your skill set when it
comes to public speaking, there are ways
that we can work together, and I can
help you do that at an accelerated rate.
Reach out to me if you are interested in
this. I would love to connect. I also
have a stand store that's below my video
content in the description, and these
are some digital products I offer you,
your ability to work with me one-on-one.
Would love to connect
if
this video added any value to you,
subscribe. Subscribe to my channel, and
the YouTube algorithm is going to
cook up some suggestion for you, so I
encourage you to check out that video as
well. Thank you so much for watching
this one. I'll catch you on the next
one.